la plupart des chansons d'edith piaf
réédité avec pour les passionnés les
inédits de son dernier concert en 63 à
l'alhambra
depuis la disparition de l'artiste son
succès ne s'est jamais démenti jean
jacques dufour et jean-louis melun sont
retournés sur les pavés de belleville là
où a grandi la môme piaf à belleville
le muguet c'est beaucoup plus qu'un
bistrot c'est un brin de souvenirs la
mémoire du paris des lits des chansons
ces gens rejoignent les qu'elle chante
noir us
mais quand il chante le clown ça me fait
frissonner
bien monsieur joue là souvent croisé à
ses débuts elle habitait à côté de chez
lui également d'être connu le champion
nordiste romain pitau qu elle faisait la
mort la faim dans le charbon vers
conques ont commandé chicago est une
coquille saint-jacques authentique et
puis très vite le petit moineau dépôt
bourg s'est envolé vers les sommets des
sommets qu'elle n'a jamais quittée
puisque des années après sa mort ses
chansons file toujours le frisson
edit c'était une voix une voix
déchirante le cri d'une m un best-of de
piaf à chaque fois vous le sortez dans
une période de fêtes c'est minimum le
disque d'or c'est à dire plus de cent
mille exemplaires à chaque fois parce
qu'à chaque fois le réussi à conquérir
un nouveau public plus jeune
ça fait partie de ces artistes qui
vendent toujours mais dit ne vont pas
des chansons elle vend la vie
on nous fait revenir à elle un jour ou
l'autre dans sa vie il ya des paroles
dans ses chansons qui donne on est
obligé de revenir à elle la porte quand
tu y vas vivre l'amour ça toujours été
là louret et les temps passeront ça sera
toujours l'amour est obligatoirement les
jeunes ils tombent amoureux aussi et
c'est un éternel recommencement
allez irremplaçable pour moi à la vôtre
et à la mémoire des dites une enfant de
la rue qu'il n'a jamais rien due à la
tricherie à la mode ou à la chance